anyway here with more of what we can
expect with these upcoming events house
oversight committee chairman uh James
Comer is with us sir good to have you
um let me ask you first you're going to
subpoena Hunter and Jim's bank records
one question has come up a lot and and
speaker McCarthy addressed this over the
weekend that Hunter Biden and likely
other family members are going to be
subpoenaed as well but my understanding
is a little there's a process behind
this
yeah right well what I said on day one
of this investigation is we were going
to follow the money and right now we've
followed the money we found the shell
companies we subpoenaed the bank records
of those shell companies we found wires
from five different countries from China
to Romania to Ukraine to Russia to uh
Uzbekistan to the Shell companies that
were then dispersed to nine different
Biden family members now we've taken the
two leading Biden family members who
received the most disbursements from
this laundered money from foreign
Nationals and that would be Hunter Biden
and Jim Biden and we're now subpoenaing
their bank records so we're following
the money once we get those bank records
and review those bank records we will
continue to follow the money if that
leads to Joe Biden or to Hunter Biden or
did Jim Biden then we will bring them in
and subpoena them but right now we've
been consistent we've been transparent
we're following the money and I can tell
you we found over 20 million dollars
that the bidens were have received from
foreign Nationals and the Biden family
cannot say one thing they did to account
for what they received that money for
you've identified nine Biden family
members that have gotten significant
amounts of money including the
grandchildren now I'd like to know
Hunter had no experience and was
struggling personally at that time of
his life what he actually did for the
money that he made because he got
millions how old were the grandchildren
do you know the ages of those that got
paid and how much money they got paid
I'd like to know what they did for the
money that they got paid
well uh one grandchild was in college
when she received the the money that had
been dispersed through the shell
companies uh from well I'd imagine she
was I imagine this grandchild was
studying and probably didn't have a lot
of time to perform a lot of duties for
the money right that would be a lot
neither conclusion the granddaughter
didn't do anything to to earn the money
the the Ex-Wives didn't do anything to
earn the money the girlfriend didn't do
anything to earn the money uh so what
what happened what transpired to earn
the money that's what every American
should be concerned about that's why we
are entering impeachment inquiry we need
all the tools necessary to get all the
information because we followed the
money and it's bad the bindings have
received millions and millions of
dollars from our enemies around the
world and no one can answer one simple
question what did they do to receive the
money we believe that this was a very
organized crime ring because the way the
money was dispersed the creation of all
the llc's and all the shell companies
and the way the money was dispersed to
the various Biden family members this
was very organized but what we've
learned from our testimony from our
transcribed interviews from also from
the emails and from the WhatsApp
messages that Joe Biden was very
involved in this he knew what the family
was doing he communicated with every
single person that wired this money to
the bidens even though he said during
the campaign he knew nothing about it
and never communicated with him let me
ask you this Nancy mace who sits on your
committee South Carolina congresswoman
told me on my radio show today that she
believes the Biden family alone when all
said and done was accumulated north of
50 million dollars you've identified
over 20 million do you believe that
number is realistic and right I do think
it's realistic because we haven't gotten
to Jim Biden yet this subpoena for Jim
Biden's personal bank records will be
the first crack at Jim Biden remember
Jim Biden didn't leave laptop lying
around so it's not been as easy to track
his transactions but he was probably
more aggressive at shaking people down
than Hunter Biden was and we know how
aggressive Hunter Biden was because he
left the laptop lying around so now
we're getting to that message I'll make
sure that between the man sitting next
to me my father and every person he
knows my ability to forever hold the
grudge that you will regret not
following my direction which implicates
his father by the way again and shortly
thereafter five million dollars was
wired that was another company I didn't
mean to interrupt you but let me ask you
this question this is important to me
um all right so 61 percent of the
American people now believe that Joe was
involved in this business dealings they
have now changed the narrative first it
was I never spoke to my son to my
brother or anybody for that matter then
it was oh the president was never in
business with his son uh now they're
claiming that uh Hunter did not share
his business or his profits with his
father which is contradicted by Hunter
saying that half his income goes to his
father it's contradicted by emails to
the money guy at Rosemont Seneca Eric
shorewind what account should I use to
pay for this home repair bill of my dad
uh 10 from the big guy so my question is
is will all these people out there
saying there's no evidence you've looked
at 170 suspicious activity reports
flagged by Banks to the treasury
Department you know you've identified
well over tens of millions of dollars
funneled into this complex web of shell
companies and llc's that would seem like
evidence to me then you look at you know
Devin Archer's testimony 20 times Hunter
uh speaking to pops with his foreign
business partners the Cafe Milano
meetings with the Russian oligarch and
others at other times uh the idea that
the 1023 form said specifically that
then Vice President Biden took specific
action in exchange for the firing of the
process executor that resulted in his
son with no experience and addicted to
drugs at the time getting paid that all
sounds like evidence to me Congressman I
don't know certainly evidence that would
raise the eyebrow of any Democrat if it
was Donald Trump's name
it's overwhelming the evidence is
overwhelming we have the bank records
we've published three Bank memorandums
this first hearing we're going to review
the evidence because so many in the
mainstream media want to want to take
the White House talking points and say
there's no evidence the evidence is
overwhelming but you look at Joe Biden
the communication where Hunter
complained about having to give half his
salary to Joe the emails you mentioned
were Joe's bills were due and Eric
Sherwin asked Hunter Biden when are you
going to pay for these bills your dad's
bills are overdue so now we're
subpoenaing the personal bank records
and we'll see where that takes us next
all right Congressman we're not buying
their lie that there's no evidence we
look forward to your continued
investigation and the testimony and the
banking records of Jim and Hunter Biden
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else